not quite as big as julius was um he
felt like him he's a mini version of him
he's got a little bit more i think of
that initial explosion julius was very
long and his explosion was good but
because of his length it seemed even
better than it really truly was i mean
jesus was phenomenal and really this is
a young man that could be that that type
of player you know i mean von miller
comes with
my mind when i watch chase and i watch
him work out and watch the tapes that
you know he's been putting out so i'm
pretty excited about seeing him
nice to have low expectations on your
way into the national football league
that's ron rivera uh my gosh high praise
for chase young but deserve it
deserve i mean he's a freak show i mean
we know that i mean yeah and i think
he's putting it the right way you know
he is more of that von miller maybe
khalil mack type guy right right around
260 pounds but nothing he won't be able
to do on an nfl field i mean great power
speed has it all instincts julius
peppers i i just don't know if everyone
and i know you've heard me say this is
just an absolute giant of a person so
you got to be careful about comparing
them now you know i've told you the
story my junior year we're playing north
carolina julius peppers and all those
players i run out to pre-game warm-ups
and he's out there at the 50-yard line
right where i'm gonna throw pat and go
and i got close to him and i went you
know me i threw out a bunch of swear
words and i was like holy crap you're
big you're julius peppers you know and
he just laughed he didn't know what to
say but he's one of those guys like a
class campbell where you're just kind of
like whoa i didn't realize you look like
this chase young has that effect but
it's more compact and muscle uh muscle
bound maybe than like a julius peppers
and they think he may be better than
nick bosa consecutive seasons out of
ohio state some excellent pass pressures
coming to the nf
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports